Professor Hein studies the effect of
technology on teams collaboration and
Innovation she's conducted extensive
research on the Dynamics of
cross-boundary work teams and particular
those spanning National borders so
welcome to folks all over the world
um Professor Hines Pam
also has a body of research on human
robot interaction in the work
environment and the Dynamics of human
robot teams and most recently Pam has
been looking at the changing nature of
work in the face of emerging
Technologies including the nature of
coordination and open Innovation and
changes in work and organizations
resulting from 3D printing and other and
the work of data analysts
before we begin for our audience please
remember you can enter in a question at
any time and I do encourage you to
submit your questions earlier
um during the webinar so don't wait
until the last minute go ahead and put
them in um and we'll go ahead and take a
look at those um as we're going through
the webinar
with that
um let's begin
Pam welcome so delighted to have you
with us today and um uh let's go ahead
and get started
um would you discuss what you
position think of is what is digital
transformation yeah great question
um and and it's kind of a complicated
question because there are a lot of
different definitions that are floating
out there and and people think of it in
different ways
um and it's different in different
contexts but I think that generally and
this is the way I think of digital
transformation is a radical reimagining
of how an organization uses technology
particularly emerging kinds of
Technology
to fundamentally change
their business models and business
performance and that includes rethinking
products Services processes and includes
emerging Technologies like AI machine
learning the expansion of data The
Internet of Things robotics social media
platforms and so forth so a host of
different kinds of emerging Technologies
but the key for me in the definition is
that it's not about incremental change
it's really this radical reimagining of
what we are delivering in terms of
products and services to our customers
and how we are operating you know what
our internal processes are for
delivering those
great thanks you know with that in mind
um you do talk a lot about culture
why is that important to digital
transformation
yeah I think it's it's critically
important because when there's a lot of
evidence at this point that
organizations that
um successfully achieve digital
transformation
undergo significant cultural change or
they're a new organization that has a
culture that aligns with what is
required to operate effectively and I'll
go into more detail on that
um but the bottom line is it can't be
done using
um existing processes systems and
structures from a decade or more ago and
part of the reason for that is because
it requires continual Innovation
um continual meaning that you know it's
not just you know a Skunk Works
operation that comes up with a new great
idea but it's something that an
organization needs to attend to on a
really constant basis in order to
um
to stay up on these rapid changes in the
technology and in the business
environment and that means that there
are fundamental changes in the
organization that are required
um for organization organizations to do
this because historically we just
haven't had to move that quickly and be
that externally focused
um you know and one of the things that
people ask is well isn't it really about
getting good digital Talent you know
knowing about these Technologies and
being able to use them effectively in
these Transformations absolutely that
that is a necessary but not a sufficient
condition for digital transformation
um because you can get overly focused
and we see organizations do this all the
time get overly focused on the digital
piece the technology piece and not on
the transformation piece
um and you know we're really talking
about
again this more fundamental radical
change
um to the way that we do business
great thank you for that
um you know you talk about the
characteristics and culture needed for
digital transformation and I'm going to
put up a slide that you and I have
talked about uh that we wanted to
discuss as part of this fireside chat
and it's kind of it's the integral
component you go into this in your your
course in the program can you talk about
the characteristics of digital culture
this diagram in particular and how it's
fundamental for every transformation
yep absolutely
um so wait the way that this diagram
came about is I read broadly about the
digital Transformations that were
successful and were unsuccessful
um over you know a I'd say decade-long
period
um and there's quite a bit that's
written there are a number of really
good books um that talk about you know
that provide these examples of
organizations that have been able to do
this successfully
and what I did was I distilled these
into the five elements that you see here
on this diagram
um one that's right in the center is
being customer Centric
um so we'll describe that in a minute
but also being Nimble and fast
really focusing on voracious learning or
a learning based culture
unbounded collaboration and appetite for
risk so those are the the five that you
see in this diagram customer Centric is
in the middle of the diagram because all
of these capabilities you know Nimble
and fast voracious learning and so forth
are employed in service of providing
customer value oftentimes through these
new business models but also new
products services and so forth so it
needs to be you know the organizations
that are most successful really focus
first on what can be provided to the
customer what needs are out there that
are not yet being met that can be met
through these Transformations so that's
the customer-centric piece
Nimble and fast the reason that that's
on there is because the pace of change
as we are embarking on these digital
transformation
requires rethinking the direction that
we're going and pivoting regularly we
need to be in a position to be able to
act on new initiatives without you know
spending a lot of time
um retooling and transitioning so it's a
combination of innovation and speed that
are required
and in order to be nimble and fast
oftentimes we need to rethink our
organizational structures you know
oftentimes our traditional hierarchical
structures get in the way of being able
to move quickly they're they're designed
for reliability not for Speed and the
same thing with our internal processes
approval processes and so forth
um can get in our way of being able to
take advantage of these opportunities
rapidly
the next one is voracious learning
um and and basically what this means is
having a culture in the organization
that's really about learning and
curiosity in order to drive new
knowledge creation
um you need to have people willing to
um you know go out and and figure things
out not just willing to but passionate
about going and learning new things and
thinking in new ways as opposed to you
know again of a very traditional
organization would be focused on hiring
people who know what you know have the
expertise that you need and then
exploiting that expertise
in this new environment of the digital
transformation
we don't necessarily know what it is
um that is going to be important the
expertise that's going to be required
and it's going to be new expertise that
is developing
um so it's really important that we have
a Workforce that is excited about and
supported in learning
um in terms of unbounded collaboration
um what I'm talking about there is being
willing to work willing to and
incentivized for working across
boundaries that are traditional within
an organization
um so having cross-functional groups
working together more actively sometimes
it means working outside of the
organization where you need to have
access to expertise that doesn't exist
within
um the the organization itself and this
is important
um two digital transformation because
these complex digital offerings
often require bringing together very
different kinds of expertise different
kinds of Technology
um
and where we may have historically been
been able to do that in tandem where
you've got one group that works on it
and hands over to another group that
hands over to another group
um and and you know there's this
iterative process
um that way
that's just not fast enough anymore
um so what it requires is bringing all
the right people into the room at the
beginning and working through these
ideas and and also that's that's a way
to
um come up with really new and novel
ideas if people are really building on
the knowledge and expertise
of others
um and then finally we have appetite for
risk and what I mean by that is an
organization that has a culture as well
as processive processes incentive
systems structures and so forth that
encourage and support risk taking
why is that important well it's because
people won't take risks they won't
innovate they won't try new things if
they are afraid that they are going to
um you know be punished in some way or
embarrassed in some way within the
organization you know they're going to
take a route that is safer for them
um so it's really important that people
feel like that it's actually a good
thing to try new things even if they
fail what's important though about this
is that it doesn't mean that everybody
can just make mistakes in their work Amy
Edmondson who's a professor at Harvard
talks about preventable failures
these are things where we we know how to
do it right and we just got sloppy
that's not the kind of risk that I'm
talking about
um
I'm talking about what she calls
intelligent intelligent failures at the
frontier
and these are failures that provide new
knowledge to the individuals and
organization
um and are good for the organization
they're actually learning opportunities
for the organization and particularly in
cases when we we actually don't know the
answer in advance we don't know whether
or not
um you know this new solution is is
going to work we don't know whether or
not there's really going to be a market
for it so how can we experiment fail
quickly
um and and move on
so I know I spoke a lot here Anita uh
but in you know kind of in summary um to
your question you know I think that
digital transformation is as much about
the transformation
as the digital
and the transformation piece requires
really rethinking organization culture
structures and systems
um you know in the way that people think
about their work and work together
excellent thanks Pam
um and thanks for for going deep in some
of these topics so uh really appreciate
you expanding on some of these ideas
um next question and
um
uh this is more of a you know say
somebody is is not a digital
transformation leader they're they're
not leading an initiative or they're a
member but they're not necessarily the
leader or they'd like to learn to get
involved or make change in their
organization so why is it important to
learn about digital transformation
even if you're not going to be the
leader but you will be a participant
yeah now that's a great question
um and you know my answer is that
nobody's immune even if you're not
leading digital transformation today
you're likely to be impacted by it
um and if not today sometime soon
according to the world economic for
Forum no industry is going to be able to
avoid digital transformation so you know
if you're thinking that well I'm in an
industry that it's not going to affect
yeah ultimately it probably will or if
you're in a role that you don't think
um will be affected or you'll be called
on to respond to digital transformation
that you know it's possible but there's
a really high likelihood that it will
affect every role throughout the
organization and and one of the reasons
is if you go back to you know what I was
talking about before in terms of the
cultural chains cultural change that's
just not just in one part of the
organization the cultural change has to
span the entire organization
um so it's it's useful to learn I think
about digital transformation so that you
understand why the organization is
shifting in the way that it is and and
actually being able to support and help
the organization in doing that even if
you're not right now on the front line
of some kind of
you know digital transformation in terms
of a particular product or service
um you know as I mentioned even
industries that are typically thought
about as being low-tech
um will be and are experiencing radical
changes
so it's important to be ready I actually
over the last few months have been
spending time at dairy farms and dairy
Farm's one of the the new technologies
that's coming in is new robotic milking
machines and they're just amazing
um you know they they're the cows
actually choose when they want to be
milked
um and they go into this system and the
system is complete with sensors there's
a dashboard that the dairy men or women
can use to monitor the health the milk
production and so forth of their cows
it'll flag whether or not there is a cow
that they should go check on and they
can do that from anywhere you know on an
on an iPad these days
um so you know even agriculture which we
think of as being pretty low-tech there
are amazing things that are happening
and happening rapidly and really
transforming what it means to work in
those Industries
um the other thing I would say is that
because successful digital
transformation requires this significant
overhaul of most organizational cultures
um you know as I said earlier most
employees are going to be affected at
least to some extent
and if you understand
those
requirements you can actually position
yourself on the front end of those
changes and help your organization
instead of being surprised and
potentially lagging behind
um and and one of the things I'll say to
Anita is in our digital transformation
program uh what we've done is identified
four courses that we think are really
important for Learners to start with
um that provide you know I think a nice
coverage of the types of changes that
are needed in organizations for
transformation ways to think about the
different kinds of technological
advances that might make sense for
particular organizations or contexts or
applications
and importantly how to effectively lead
these efforts so those courses are
they all start with this x d g t I'm
going to ignore that first one is number
100 and that is foundation's digital
transformation and that goes into more
detail on what I was talking about
earlier in terms of those five different
aspects of uh the the foundational
culture that an organization needs
uh the next one I'll mention is 224
which is building an AI enabled
organization and this is a really I
think fun course because it looks across
a broad swath of Industries at the
different ways that AI can actually
enable
um
new products and services
so that's I I find that course to be
really kind of inspirational
um the other one is 223 which is
building a product platform strategy to
accelerate growth so in this course we
really look at
products and kind of the traditional
product strategy and platforms and how
you bring those together in a way that
is really aligned with what you're
trying to accomplish and what the
strategy is for the organization
and Professor Eisner teaches that brings
in lots of nice case studies and so
forth
and then the the last one I'll mention
is the in the fourth one on the list is
uh 111.
um and this course is systems leadership
managing uncertainty in the digital age
um and this very much focuses on how to
be a more effective leader when things
are uh more complex and more uncertain
um so that's one that that everybody can
benefit particularly in this day and age
thank you and and thanks for talking
about the the core courses that's
something new that we've added to the
program to uh give uh our Learners our
customers
um a Learning Journey that would uh be
appropriate for them depending upon
where they are in their career
um whether they're focused more on a
managerial path or technical uh
technical track
um so that thank you for expanding on
that um why we picked those four courses
and then I also do want to mention that
um on your screens for those of you who
are with us today you can also see
another opportunity this is one of our
first opportunities to invite uh
Learners customers to come to the
Stanford campus in late January we're
hosting a course on campus where you can
learn from digital transformation our
faculty members that teach in this
program and you can learn more by
clicking on there's is a link there for
the program which is called Innovation
strategy in a digital world and our
customer service can answer any
additional questions you might have
we have about five minutes left and so I
would love it if you would answer a
question from one of our guests here
today
this is
um how do you overcome organizational
resistance to transformation
and we we know this one comes up a lot
um especially when uh the folks in
charge
um uh might not be aligned
um to support that change
um and uh you know you talk about risk
and not only this from the the the the
people that are actually going to make
the change implement the changes whether
it's managerial process technology but
the executives that have to be
comfortable with that risk can you talk
a little bit about that
yeah I mean that that's hard
um because for the type of
um change that I'm talking about
um it really requires high level
leadership if you're going to change
your organizational structures if you're
going to change your organizational
culture if you're going to encourage and
not punish risk and that really does
trickle down from the top of the
organization in the absence of that
somebody who is sort of leading from
the middle if you will uh one of the
things that has worked really well
um
is what we call small wins and that is
doing something look more locally
to prove out the importance of doing
this
um so that you know because because
oftentimes the reason that people are
resistant is because
um they are concerned about the risk
they're not convinced that it really is
important or is going to be successful
or the organization can do it
effectively so to be able to prove that
out in small ways with the resources
that you have available
is a good way to get people's attention
and then you can
um you know publicize those small wins
and hopefully over time
um although hopefully quickly too
because things are moving quickly
get more
um support from leadership in the
organization and the other thing too is
to to look for leaders that are
supportive you know even if there is
some resistance there are probably other
leaders in the organization that get it
um so you know uh working with them as
as allies as
um
you know a team that can kind of develop
and
um Champion
um these these small wins and these
changes
um I I'm going to try and squeeze in one
more question
um and um what do you foresee as a
future of digital transformation
oh yeah
um so that's the million dollar question
um and I wish I had a crystal ball
um to predict but you know in terms of
the the
details of it it's hard because because
these are Innovations and we don't know
right by the nature of
um what we're talking about in terms of
transformation we don't know but what I
can say with confidence
is that
um
we we can pretty much guarantee that
there will be continued disruptions
um to organizations and to Industries
driven by these advances in Technologies
and these Innovative new business models
products services and so forth
that capitalize on those Technologies
and those advances and that includes
everything that we're seeing out there
AI machine learning sensors digital
traceability virtual and augmented
reality smart materials Robotics and so
on and so forth and and perhaps most
importantly the integration of these
Technologies
um for new products services and
processes within the organization so I
guess the two things just to summarize
that I would predict is we're going to
see continued disruptions and we're
going to see more and more integration
of these Technologies in order to affect
the kind of transformation
that we're going to be seeing
great thank you
um let's see here I'm trying to see if I
can squeeze in one more question
one more minute if you if you had to do
uh
um one last thing good few words of why
digital transformation in one minute
why digital transformation oh
um why why is it happening
uh why why the program
oh
um yeah I guess it would go back to what
I was saying earlier which is this is an
inevitability
um for for all of us right and it's not
you know even in in education we're
experiencing this you know it's it is it
is pervasive and you know I I it is
always better to be in the know and be
able to anticipate some of these things
so that so that we can get ahead of them
and and have an impact and make a
contribution and potentially even you
know choose different career paths
um depending upon
where we think we can
um can contribute
fantastic thank you Pam thank you for
that last impromptu question to you
um I want to thank everybody who joined
us today and
um your participation the there will be
a recording of This that um will be
shared with you within a few days and
um thank you again Pam and thank you all
for joining us for this first of a kind
uh fireside chat for the Stanford
digital transformation program and I
wish you all a wonderful day
um and journey through your career
thanks thank you thank you Anita and
thank you everyone